normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
jump to this story here this is the this
is the bigger news that we were going to
get into initially but we pushed it back
here we go from DC Dro he says and there
it is Senator Dick Durban is finally
revealing their grand plan flood the
country with illegal aliens and list
them in the military and make them
citizens the part he isn't disclosing is
who the marxists will use the alien who
the marxists will use the alien soldiers
against ah yes interesting the funny
thing is that we we've talked about this
and I've I've speculated this would uh
be the case we have massive shortfalls
in our military and we have a massive
illegal immigration uh population coming
across the border I said how long until
they send all these guys to Ukraine no
joke now now here's my question to all
the Republicans who are upset about
illegal immigration you got Texas saying
we're going to send them to Martha's
Vineyard or whatever or Florida in Texas
okay what if we send them all to
Ukraine new rule new law United States
if you enter this country country
illegally we won't Deport you we will
send you to Ukraine I'm not saying make
them fight I am not saying force them to
join any kind of government action I am
not saying we're involved in anymore I
am saying quite literally the
deportation process is not a return to
your home country all non-citizens who
are here illegally and facing
deportation sent to Ukraine of course
then Ukrainian government will take them
hand them a weapon and say to the front
lines with ye but you know that's uh but
I'm fine if they're they're in the
Ukrainian military I don't want them to
join our military right like if you're
in the middle of committing the crime of
illegally entering my country I don't
think you have my country's best
interest at heart I don't necessarily
want you to be in my military and then
be you know have access to the GI bill
or whatever else that doesn't make sense
to me let me let me play this clip you
can hear it for yourselves what troubles
me about the debate now about the
southern border is it is one/ half of
the immigration equation yes we need
order at the border yes we need to have
changes in the laws that reflect the
reality of the over overwhelming numbers
from all over the world who are coming
to our our Shores and our border but
there is also an incredible demand for
legal immigration into this country even
now the presiding officer my colleague
from the state of Illinois has
legislation which addresses one aspect
of that her bill and I hope I describe
it accurately says that if you are an
undocumented person in this country
undocumented person in this countrygal
immigrant invader and you can pass the
physical and the required test
background test the like you can serve
in our military and if you do it
honorably we will make you citizens of
the United States do we need that no do
you know what the recruiting numbers are
at the Army and the Navy in the Air
Force they can't reach their quotas each
month they can't find enough people to
join our military forces and there are
those who are undocumented who want the
chance to serve and risk their lives for
this country sedition should we give
them a chance no I think we should this
is sedition you're incorrect dick they
have created policies that are destroy
that's destroying the US armed forces
and now they are advocating to have
non-citizens serve in our armed forces
the Armed Forces will be
replaced from citizens to non-citizens
and then when the order is given to fire
an American citizen they're going to say
I don't care yeah it doesn't make any
sense and he's saying we're having
trouble recruiting people so instead of
trying to address that issue just going
to bring in people who are here
illegally and give them a path to
citizenship right let's fix like why
we're having trouble like why did you
fire all the unvaccinated why are you
pushing woke crap and Dei down these
troops throats they hate it they don't
want it they're not willing to die for a
country that you know hates them and
hates their founding and I think what
they're doing is you know they are
trying to bring people here who have no
allegiance to America's founding because
when the time comes they'll be willing
to turn the guns on all of us right cuz
they have no allegiance to us no respect
for our laws as you said they're coming
here illegally already it's crazy yeah
and it seems like it like I don't
understand how any humanitarian would be
like great idea dict derin I love this
because now you're holding citizenship
over someone's head being say go fight
in a war potentially die to get
citizenship the thing about being an
American citizen and enlisting the
military is that you already have that
right so you're of service to your own
country it seems like a crazy prospect
on both sides to say that anyone would
benefit from this at all it seems like
blackmail on one hand I know you're here
illegally you have now registered with
the government to be fair the Biden
Administration doesn't Deport anyone
they're useless but theoretically I know
you're here illegally so continue to
fight until I say you can stay here or
we could just maybe enforce border laws
and then go back to our native
population and say why don't you want to
enlist in the military what changed in
our culture that drove military
recruitment down what's going on in the
military like you've alluded to all
sorts of like woke ads the the
vaccination regulations as well as just
generally like what are the physical
fitness standards what are the benefits
what what what are we doing that's not
working rather than bring in a class of
illegal people why don't we just go to
people who are already here are citizens
and ask them what would make you want to
be in the military well then these
people who come here illegally are still
a burden on the taxpayer right we're
still being paying for them to be here
paying for all of the benefits that they
get as members of the military and will
get when they leave the military so you
know you're not in any way taking this
problem away from the American taxpayer
you might even be making it worse one
could argue it doesn't make any sense we
could give less Ben benefits to
foreigners that join the military but
give them citizenship as their benefit
but isn't that like a form of
discrimination saying you're doing the
same job but you get fewer benefits that
doesn't make any sense also it would be
a for should you want to fight for your
own country I mean shouldn't you be a
citizen to enlist in the military how do
we know where your loyalties are if
you're not a citizen of the country
you're serving absolutely I think these
people in particular recent you know
people that are crossing over their
southern border have shown they have no
interest in assimilating right they're
waving their foreign Flags they're not
not adhering to our values people used
to come to the US and literally change
their last name so they could pass as
American that's how badly they wanted to
assume our identity and adhere to our
culture and these people aren't doing
that at all they're shoving it in our
faces so to think that they would want
to fight under the banner of the
American flag you know honestly and
believe in it I think that's just stupid
I think about the hessin the having
foreign Nationals Fight for Your Country
it's not super uncommon the British
hired the German hessin uh to fight the
during the American Revolution and uh
against the colonists and also like but
you see like the Roman Empire started to
hire and bring in foreigners to fight a
late stage Empire when they didn't like
I said if Ukraine wants to hire
America's illegal immigrants to go fight
for their War that's fine but I don't
think that as the country the US should
say as a path to citizenship we should
encourage illegal immigration it's the
same reason that you make with ending
Birthright citizenship right if you say
if you have a child in this country you
get to stay then people are like what
can I do to have a child in that country
and if I were to say if you enlist our
military you get to stay I'm undermining
the actual problem which is that people
should not be illegally entering into
our country and then being expected to
find a way to assimilate and benefit
especially because they didn't respect
the country in the first place to get
there yeah and I'm just really tired of
politicians trying to fix you know
symptoms of the problem and not actually
get to the root of it we have the
capacity to totally stop the illegal
immigration at our Southern border we
just don't have politicians who are
willing to do that all right well how
about this one from Florida's voice this
is not normal the santis warned of
invasion as group of Chinese Nationals
crosses the border so uh how many of the
people that they're going to put in our
uh military or non-citizens are going to
be I don't know Iranian or you mean
fighting age men from other countries
that don't have our best interest at
heart and particularly those from China
or they get officer status then they
have access to sensitive data yo people
you want to talk about this is a funny
thing when I talk about uh Civil War and
they're like it'll never happen I I love
this one when I would ask people I would
ask people this 20 years ago if uh uh a
US military man was ordered to fire on
an American citizen would they do it and
the immediate reaction from everyone is
no they would not and I'm like that's
the stupidest thing ever of course they
would for the same reason why police
shoot guys in their pickup trucks when
they're on a highp speed chase the the
the Assumption with the question is that
there's there's just like two Rand like
a random guy walking on the street
there's always some kind of reason and
if it comes down to there's a mass
protest and someone is ordered like by
any means stop this guy he's a fugitive
he's dangerous do you think like and and
I'm not trying to single out military
personel I'm saying anyone in law
enforcement they're not going to operate
under the assumption that the person
they're going after is a San rational
individual they're being told by the
superiors these are the actions you take
this person is considered armed and
dangerous okay so you've got a National
Guard out and and they and they brief
them and say we're there's going to be
riots and there's going to be live ammo
and fully automatic rifle
do not under you know blah blah blah and
then if something was happening and
someone was firebombing something and
they said that guy stop him now open
fire like there's there's not a
situation where they're going to be like
well hold on there commanding officer I
understand there's something happening
in front of me but I'm going to go ahead
and not do that there there are certain
circumstances where imagine it's a
regular guy walking on the street
carrying a newspaper someone might be
like I don't know what's going on but
even then you have you have the issue of
uh to the the example I like to use is
the boss ver Bridge coup attempt in
Turkey these guys are being told
something right you're going out you're
you're you're working in security they
don't think like the commanding officer
isn't saying yeah I'm a villain and I
want to kill a random person I order you
to do it because then they're going to
say no there's typically some kind of
reason but even outside of that look
where we are now people people have I've
talked about Civil War and they say oh
the military is not going to fight the
American people blah blah blah this
military will a bunch of Chinese and
Honduran Nationals who are in the US
Army and the National Guard who are are
deployed to quell a riot from a bunch of
American Born people in Staten Island
you got the people in Staten Island
protesting that they're busing in
non-citizens and giving them their and
giving the tax money from the citizens
to the non-citizens the citizens protest
these guys CH the National Guard they or
open fire they're not going to think
twice yeah because they have no respect
for our founding ideology like when you
hear you know CIA or FBI or doj
whistleblowers talk what they always say
is you know I felt that this went
against our found belief system it was
against the Constitution I felt I
couldn't you know do this raid on my
fellow man who did no wrong these people
don't have that kind of ideology or
approached anything at all they're
already coming here they're breaking
laws um they're going to shoot the satin
Island protester no doubt the the the
assumption is an American citizen you
know American as apple pie is told to
open fire on an American citizen who is
also as American as apple pie and it's
like whoa whoa I can't do that that's my
neighbor and my brother and he's flying
the American flag dude you will get some
proud boy type dude with an American
flag or Trump supporter waving a flag
and screaming and protest and there will
be a guy from Honduras or from uh
Ecuador or even from Africa because
we've had we've had illegal uh
immigrants they fly from Africa into
Brazil and then travel all over the
southern border they're going to be
given positions in not just the military
take a look at this one from WTTW new
Illinois law that allows certain
non-citizens to join law enforce it
becomes a flasho point that's right
there's going to be a cop who shows up
and he's is going to say I don't know
you I don't care about you my life was
bad I have been given an opportunity
anything they tell me to do I will do
and you had that story where there was a
Somali migrant who killed that woman in
her car for no reason you remember that
one it was Minnesota or whatever for no
reason he just kills this woman un like
it was like a park was what was it like
a speeding ticket or something can't
remember the story this woman like did
like nothing like her headlights out and
he's like okay and he shoots her and
kills her what do you think's going to
happen when you have non-citizens your
military it's the inmates running the
asylum
yeah I go back to I think it's more like
the Legion of Doom to this business plot
I mean this is this is just insane
business plot you got to just educate
yourself on the business plot Smedley
Butler American retired General World
War I General they wanted him to be to
lead a fascist overthrow and he said no
if he had said yes we'd be living under
a tyrant right now we probably would
have joined the na I just got I just got
to stop you I I don't believe any of
that if this guy we under tyranny we we
we are dealing with them putting
noncitizens in law enforcement they're
giving non-citizens the right to vote
the Biden Administration actually had
border patrol cut the barrier and shut
the barriers down so this idea that
there was some coup a 100 years ago is
meaningless when right now we are living
under tyrants yeah that was the attempt
at legitimizing their coup was that
business plot but if Smedley Butler
didn't have American ideals is the point
I'm bringing it up if he had been a
foreign National that it Rose to the
rank of General because of service and
then they'd ask him to go become the
dictator if he's from Somalia I'm not
saying Somalia is a bad place but
somewhere where dictatorships were Norm
you could see and for all you know this
guy the actual plot was we want you to
go to Congress and claim there's a plot
to legitimize the removal of the gold
standard and the and and strength in the
Federal Reserve and he smirked and said
yes these ideas that we just believe
these narratives and Trust all of it is
is is meaningless tole Butler was like
the most decorated General on Earth at
the time so what it's 100 years ago and
it's irrelevant to the point that right
now regardless of what happened we're
looking at dick Durban out of Illinois
saying noncitizens in the military and
we're looking at Illinois same place so
the saying noncitizen law en Smedley
Butler had been a non-citizen in in that
situation and they go to a non-citizen
they're like hey overthrow you a
noncitizen is way more likely I think
the thing is America isn't just oh we
live here and so therefore we are
American American is a is a cultural and
philosophical belief there is more
behind it than just oh I happen to have
residents or happen to have stumbled
into this area and live there right and
that's why it works why there is common
value it's why you could have multiple
states that also share commonality we
don't work like separate countries
entirely uh what I find to be
challenging is that dick Durban is
saying well we have these people here
and so we should just let them be
citizens if they trade in some way it's
undermining what really we need to
address which is our cultural issues
which is why people don't want to enlist
in the military I think that just saying
we should replace the populations that
that's here because they aren't doing
the job that we want is not the answer
answer it just will ultimately create
some long-term problems and and I will
clarify too for the super chatter Dante
scar Scarlet saying it's illegal
immigrants we're concerned about it's
not as much non-citizens but it is still
in my opinion partly non-citizens it it
is true that there are people who who
are not citizens who join the military
and we have had programs where you're
not a citizen join the military you can
become a citizen the difference uh uh
between illegal immigrant and that is
very clear however regardless I would
not be very happy with a uh Mass
mobilization of non-citizens in any
capacity be it illegal immigrant or
permanent resident and the thing is Dick
Durban says we need more legal
immigration too which I just
fundamentally disagree with because it's
the same argument right people here
aren't doing the thing we want so let's
bring in someone else rather than go to
our native population and say how can we
get you into these roles that we need
fills what can we do to Rally as a
country and solve our own problems I
think this is what's what's upsetting
about the immigration debate which is
that there are lot I mean most both of
my parents are immigrants they came to
America they chose to be here that was
good right I was raised as an American I
have cultural ties elsewhere but this is
not the same thing when you come
illegally when you come illegally
because you see some social benefit but
you don't actually want to be a part of
the country it's very different the
first thing you could do would be to
show respect to the country and abide by
their laws including their immigration
laws which are frustrating and I
understand that but illegal immigrants
are not going through the same process
that legal imits are going going through
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net